it's
different oh
no hi my name is chris halvig oh and i
forgot how this
goes oh hi my name is grace hellman if
you do not know now you know your life
is different now
welcome to a new kitchen not only am i
going back to school
but i moved in the last couple weeks so
just a few minor things going on in my
life another minor thing
it's no pants november i
finally feel like we can get back to the
real business
at hand in the world right yes
i am so okay so many things have
happened i love tennis apparently
get these items no distractions only
only only
the um focus okay what are we doing
we're in a new kitchen but we're still
doing the same [ __ ]
no pants but we're gonna be in the
inside yeah love to hate it right
i haven't had my hair done in six months
so it's like a band-aid over a bullet
hole up here this is the first time i'm
cooking
a hellofresh in my new kitchen with a
camera on i have cooked hello fresh in
this kitchen before so things work in
this kitchen
this kind of works in this kitchen it's
been an
intense [ __ ] month huh are you as
exhaustedly filled with hope as i am
yeah i think we all deserve a
comforting meal and that's why today
we're making
sleepy joes i'm sorry sloppy joes i'm
sorry
i was right the first time sleeping gels
we're living in sleepy joe's america
everybody i couldn't be more excited so
how appropriate
is it that today we're making ancho
barbecue sloppy joes or as i like to
call them
sleepy joes because not only do i like a
president that sleeps
i like food that makes me sleep we all
deserve to take a little bit of a rest
before the rest of the work gets done so
let's
fuel up our tanks for slumber with some
sloppy
sloppy joes that sounds concerning i
have so much room to do activities like
this
but before we cook we have to talk and
get to the point i'm talking about
talking points
[Music]
[Music]
is america's number one meal kit that's
right now for you so many different
recipes to get out of the rut that you
might find yourself in in the kitchen
they got low calorie recipes they got
kid-friendly recipes they got vegetarian
recipes
all of their recipes can get on the
table in just about 30 minutes 20
minutes if you try their quick and easy
recipes
all of their ingredients are
pre-measured pre-packaged so there's
less prep and less food waste for you
they're super flexible so you can change
your delivery dates you can change your
meal preferences whenever you like
and they're dedicated to giving back
they donated over 2.5 million meals to
charities in 2019
and amid the coronavirus they're
dedicated to doing even more food
donations this year
i hope fresh man i'm just oozing
artistic
passion today without further ado let's
get into making this meal because i'm
hungry and we all deserve a hot
pile of slop sleepy joes america
everybody oh feels good
no eggs is exactly correct there are no
eggs
what do we got you guys look lovely you
all came dressed
up step one we're gonna roast our
potatoes potatoes
the comedy never stops create our oven
let's preheat our vocal cords for a
second
i'm blue da boo dee da boo 450
oven buttons make noise that's how you
know
it works perfect we're gonna wash our
potatoes and cut them into slices
and put them in the oven with salt
pepper and olive oil
and bake them up it sounds like i know
what i'm doing if you say a sentence all
the way through with confidence
that really tricks people into thinking
you know what you're doing we've been
dealing with that for the last
four years potatoes pot a bunch of
states new jersey included past
legalizing marijuana and that just makes
me happy too
the election wasn't as perfect as we
hoped or imagined it could be but we got
some good [ __ ] done so let's focus on
some good
i keep going why i don't get into
politics i can't
rile the masses i can rile a mass though
one favorite pastime of mine is was
walking into a catholic church and
screaming prove it i'd kid
let's cut these guys into disks and
cooking we're already [ __ ]
cooking so how have you guys been just
on the
craziest roller coaster of emotions yeah
but at least we were in it together
and didn't we all have the most joyous
saturday oh
that was so aggressively blissful
quick science lesson this is not the
shape of the earth politics science what
are we going to talk about next
math you numbers exist pornacki has
already proven numbers i hope that guy's
taking a nap right now tornacki you did
a great job i love
bbs big bird big board potatoes go on
the baking
sheet oh one on the floor that's a sign
of good luck we'll put a little more
olive oil on these guys as a salt and
pepper
i'm gonna grope you with your consent
cool thank you
should have thought about this sleeve
situation before we got into this
business but this is okay this is how
rachel ray does it let's wash her hands
you should have done that before we
started doing this but you know what we
already did it before we started rolling
the camera
and i can't prove it but you're just
gonna have to believe in me the same way
you do the thing in church okay um
that's gonna get cut out i respect all
of your religious beliefs and freedoms
okay sorry i was looking at my phone for
a second
that's so rude the oven's still heating
up once that preheats to 450 these will
go in the oven in the meantime i forgot
i froze the beef
yo get out of your basement bunker
and come be part of this presidency
let's defrost this ground beef oh they
gave us a pickle in a bag
i love pickles in a bag not only is
this a high school health class
educational visual aid always wrap up
your pickle in a bag but it's also
the dumbest most hilarious way that a
snack exists i love pickles and bags
it's just stupid and it feels like it
should be disgusting but it's very clean
great parting gifts i hope the entire
trump family on their way out of the
white house gets a pickle in a bag as a
parting gift okay
we have some time so look at everything
a little bit
move on we're gonna be efficient we're
gonna half peel and dice this onion i
don't care if you make me cry onion
because i've been crying
all weekend long so lovely to cry happy
cheers how did
everyone celebrate leave some comments
down below what was the
funniest silliest sweetest thing that
you saw or did
over the previous weekend onion is diced
half our buns what else is going on
nothing because this is taking
everyone's mental energy and focus
it cut me off but potatoes are going to
go in the oven for 18 to 20 minutes
until they're crispy
uh the sunlight of that
dark cabaret you get it i got a rogue
hair
just trying to tell my eyes what's up
hey kay you guys have talked long enough
get away
like every activity if you find yourself
at a standstill don't know what to do
just wash your hands thinly slice our
pickle into rounds
oh my god it's a pickle it's so stupid
whoever came up with that
i'm sure you were discouraged when you
first pitched pickle in a bag
but thank you for really following
through i love
pickles they're just like cucumbers with
a personality
cucumbers that clap back cucumbers that
don't like to get
gas lit small bowl barbecue sauce
ketchup ketchup in a bag not as
satisfying as a pickle in a bag but i
trust that you're you're trying chili
powder am i doing all of it
yeah well i'm doing all of it stop
concentrate i need you to concentrate
half the cornstarch a tablespoon of
water oh god oh god oh god we combined
it look at this you can't smell it but
it smells
like barbecue sauce a lot and
beef whoa hello oh this is a very
curious smell
smells like a delicious tire now we're
on to step three
we're gonna need a large pan heat a
drizzle of oil in a large pan over
medium
high heat add onion and cook for four to
five minutes
oh that seemed like that could have been
should have been done
safer all right so now we have some time
to just chit chat
um
so what do you like to do for fun
i gotta have a boyfriend i do not know
how to date who else isn't wearing pants
today
sorry for the sound so while that cooks
and the sound is a little bit
bad i'm just gonna kind of like touch
things um to feel like i'm
doing stuff and that i'm just alive
who's ready to vote in georgia in
january
make sure that you're registered to vote
if you're turning 18 in january
you can register to vote so make sure
you go do that check it out i'll leave
links in the
freaking description down below that's
so serious i haven't about you doing
this
democracy the onions have been cooking
for a number of minutes that have
reached the maximum capacity of my
patients so now we're going to add our
beef
and we're going to season with some
pepper sorry vegetarians i respect your
choices
breaking up the base i'm getting all hot
and unbothered
let's focus or not we can do whatever we
want
no we should follow the rules i'm gonna
get a little closer to you in the
microphone the beef is basically cooked
so now we're gonna add the barbecue
mixture
this fun stuff to the pan and cook for
another two to three minutes
wow the potatoes have been cooking this
whole time it's like when you leave
something to do its job it does it
potatoes potatoes it's my favorite song
what are those potatoes
things are like getting done well and i
don't want to freak anyone the [ __ ] out
myself included mostly only all right so
our beef mixture is cooked it said that
we can toast the buns
while the beef mixture is cooking and i
didn't do that part
should we do that part i guess we should
do that part
yeah okay okay let's do that part do we
want to do that part
let's try and toast the buns real quick
oh my god and then we're like basically
done and we just have to make our plates
this is going really well i'm gonna
toast these buns and then i'm going to
get my plate together
and we'll see where we're at oh you're
so sleepy joe
wow wow
this is how it looks on the campaign
trail and this is how it wins the
presidency
and you're like yeah joe let's make
america sleepy again
you guys okay guys as always
you get a deal on hellofresh for being
here existing
and participating in this democracy
which is a grace helvetic cooking video
if you go to hellofresh.com
use the code hellbig90 you'll get 90
off including free shipping on your
first box again go to hellofresh.com
use the code hellbig90 for 90
off and free shipping on your first box
okay let's try this sleepy joe
i'm gonna do my impression of america
you do your impression of sleepy joe
and we'll see how it feels to put you in
our mouth
wow delicious you are messy and sloppy
but it's not like i wasn't a [ __ ]
mess
before i met you that's really good i
haven't had a sloppy joe in
god since college it is exactly what it
says it is
it's healing it is warm it's
compassionate it has a plan as a plan to
get into my guts and clean it out
well thank you guys so much for watching
this cooking video in the new
house i hope you enjoyed it i definitely
did everything
works i'm happy i hope you are too if
you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to this youtube
channel i'll be making more hello fresh
videos in the future for sure along with
some other videos so
get ready and um
i don't know here we go
look now this is a garbage bag oh my
gosh
i'm a genius i've always said it
i'm a genius and the real people
geniuses lack humility and that's
exactly what i am a genius why am i
taking so long to try and this is what
am i doing
okay just thank you for that dance bag i
guess you'll just do that
great